my name is David shank and I'm author of
a new book called the genius in all of
us
genius is an amorphous term to be sure
and I actually try to stay away from it
in the book the what I what I talk about
in the book mostly is this idea of high
achievement so people becoming great at
stuff becoming really really good at
stuff I don't think it's really
important to make a dividing line some
to try to figure out you know when
you've crossed over into into genius the
point is gathering your resources doing
the best you can pursuing whatever it is
you love to do with with an intensity
and a resilience and a passion and and
just going as far as you can possibly go
we've been living with this myth for
about a hundred hundred and fifty years
going back to the time of Darwin
although I'm not blaming Darwin for this
all they've if the blame resides
anywhere it's really with Darwin's
cousin Francis Galton and we can get
into that if you like but so the idea is
that we we think that its nature versus
nurture that there's there's genes that
that have all this information that kind
of want to push us in a certain
direction and then there's the
environment which is nurture which is
which is obviously different and kind of
an opposing force and and it's kind of
either/or and there's all these studies
that are constantly trying to figure out
well how much is nature and then add on
to the nurture you know is it 60-percent
nature and 40% nurture depending on what
trait you're talking about well it turns
out that genes don't work that way genes
don't get you part of the way they're
you know to the point you're born or the
point shortly after that or before that
genes are always interacting with the
environment so the new way to think
about this is that it's not nature plus
nurture or nascent nature versus nurture
if anything its nature interacting with
nurture if you have to use those words
so one of the phrases that scientists
are using now is G times e that is
genetics times environment as opposed to
G + E ISM that they call it an additive
model the additive model as well you
have so much inborn intelligence and
then plus what you get in the
environment that would be you know the
nature of plus nurture the new the new
model is you can't separate them you
just absolutely cannot separate the
effects of genes from the effects of the
environment so all we can do of course
is to identify the resources that we
have in our environments and and
maximize them as best as best we can
one of the studies is goes back to 1957
or 58 where these two guys were looking
at at rats that had been genetically
designed the genetically bred that is to
be intelligent and in generation after
intelligent they were incredibly
intelligent in you know is seen in mazes
and things like that so then they wanted
to see well what if you subject them to
different environments extreme
environments like sensory deprivation
kind of thing or extra treats and you
know so-called intellectual stimulation
for rats if you can imagine what that is
it basically it's lots of toys and
different textures and sounds and sights
and colors and things like that and they
wanted to see well what's the additive
difference of the environment if you
take these these these mice that have
been bred to be smart compared to these
mice that have been bred to be not so
smart well turns out that when you
subject them to these different
environments actually the mice that are
that have have been supposedly bred to
be unintelligent quite often intersect
with the the intelligence the
performance of the mice that have been
bred to be intelligent and the reason is
that you're getting these interactions
which you couldn't have predicted if you
were looking at the old additive model
of G + E so so that was one of the very
early clues that we're looking at a
whole new model of genes and environment
that it was this interactive model
q from Darrell Trafford who is probably
the world's foremost authority on
autistic savants and this is a really
interesting idea we look at savants you
know Rain Man and things like that and
we think oh well that's obvious
obviously evidence of innate gifts
because these guys are obviously born
with different sorts of brains and it's
and it's these they're born with these
these gifts that are able to you know
remember every calendar date you know
going back to the year 1200 or whatever
well when you actually look at what's
going on yes these people are born with
with with birth defects if that's what
you want to call them their brains are
certainly wired differently there's no
question about that but it turns out
that the the actual skills that they
acquire then come after that and that we
can actually manipulate our own brains I
mean there's the word is plasticity
everyone watching this has heard the
term plasticity there isn't really any
there there's a difference in in in in
quantity between what these these
savants are born with and what we could
do or their own brains there isn't
really a qualitative difference we can
alter our own brains and you don't
actually develop the skills to do what
the guy in Rain Man did or these other
amazing savants do until you have those
differences are already in place so in
other words it's the it's the process of
developing these skills not just being
born with the skill or the gift and if
I'm trying to do anything in this book
it's it's trying to help people
understand that the the old notion of
innate the old notion of giftedness the
notion that we are born with a certain
quantity of intelligence or quantity of
talent
it really isn't there we're all born
with differences no question about that
we have genetic differences but what
those differences turn out to be in the
end result how those genetic differences
actually lead to differences in traits
that's a dynamic process that we are all
very much involved with in the fit on
the family level as parents as kids
ourselves culturally
nutrition environment everything we do
and everything we are is is an ongoing
interactive process which affects how
those genes are then going to be
subsequently turned into the traits that
work for us and against us
yeah big question hard to care to give
you a you know a catch-all answer
obviously with sensitivity I would say
that first of all a monumentally
important is a parent who wants their
child to be great at something
absolutely cannot put love out there as
kind of reward for becoming good at
something
it actually works in the short term you
can get a child to be really really good
and really really motivated by saying
you know I'm not gonna show you
affection until you get you know until
you get to be really good at you know
cross a certain skill level but it's a
disaster emotionally for kids and it
gets even worse as as they grow up
parents need to help their kids
understand that first of all whatever
they are is okay secondly it's not only
okay to fail it's tough it's actually
good to fail it's tough you cannot learn
until you fail every time you fail it's
you
if you are open to that being a learning
experience why you failed at something
then then then that is the gateway into
learning and then you combine that with
persistence with this idea that you know
the people who get graded stuff it
requires just pushing and pushing and
pushing and never stop pushing kind of
enjoying the process and embracing the
failure as I said and and never being
quite satisfied you know having a
certain contentment with the process
enjoying who you are and wherever you
are wherever you're at skill wise but
also knowing that there's more to do and
and and that over time you will get
better at stuff if you if you push
yourself I know that sounds kind of
mundane but that turns out to be true
so why do why did child prodigies fizzle
out well there are a couple reasons one
is that very important to realize that
when kids are immensely great at
something playing the violin or
particularly good at a sport or having
some sort of what looks like a gift in
in in another art or skill they're never
performing at an adult great level
they're only sticking out for what other
kids can do and the reason that that's
really important to point out is that
they're great at a technical skill I'm
not trying to take away from from what
they do because obviously it is amazing
to watch and when you have particularly
when your parent you've seen all these
kids your kids and other kids performing
in a relatively average level in some
way and then you see some other kid just
doing something amazing you're you're
you're blown away by it but it's
important to realize that you know for
example when you look at Mozart yes he
was performing for kings and queens when
he was five six years old but his
performances then were not could not be
compared to a great violinist of twenty
five or thirty years old he couldn't be
then and it certainly couldn't be now
another point to make is that with the
Suzuki method and other methods now
there are many many many performers now
who are performing at that age five to
six years old seven years old as good or
better than what Mozart did when he was
a kid so we tend to think of we tend to
hold Mozart up on this pedestal as being
this having this god-given gift and
being one in a zillion in terms of his
early musicality but but in actuality
it's fairly easy if you look at his life
to explain where he where he got the
skills that he got and to identify them
as skills not as some sort of
supernatural power and to see that now
we are culture has actually learned a
lot of the trade secrets that at the
time maybe only Leopold Mozart knew and
and we're applying them left and right
to
two very young kids
yeah I think I think this is uki method
this school is really exciting as long
as everything's in perspective you you
want to follow the child's lead you know
you want to introduce them to two great
teachers and expose them to music as
early as possible that's that's a
wonderful thing in it leads it to all
sorts of other other benefits in life
but you don't want to push them
unnaturally you want to you know you
want to try pushing them a little bit
and see if they push back and say you
know what I'm not ready for this or yeah
this is something I really want to do
you want to kind of take their
temperature as to what their passions
are and their their persistence
great questions so people you're right
people look at people and people we call
geniuses people are at the very very top
of their field everything what do they
have they must have some kind of
quantity that all these other people
don't have that and they must have been
born with that because you can't you
can't see what it is so that's what this
researcher named Anders Ericsson wanted
to know and it's been now kind of made a
not only his own lifetime of study but
it's kind of built this army of
researchers to study what the invisible
processes of our of talent and of
acquiring skills and of going from
mediocrity to to being really good at
stuff it turns out that it's a kind of
persistence and a way of embracing
failure which Erickson calls deliberate
practice so the idea is you push
yourself slightly beyond your skill
level and you you want to fail you want
to comparing say a violinist who's
practicing it's not it's not just the
idea is when you're practicing you're
not just trying to reinforce what you
already can do you are reinforcing what
you already can do and then trying to do
it faster or better or with more emotion
or more dynamism but whatever you're
shooting for and you're pushing yourself
until you can't until you find a place
where you can't quite you can't quite
get there and then you work at that and
you work at that and you work at that
and it's not the enjoyable Erickson
really emphasize this it's not the
enjoyable part of practice you have to
somehow and the difference I think this
is this is the one of the keys in the
difference of personalities between
people who get good and stuff or or get
greatest stuff is the people who get
great at stuff really enjoy not in a fun
way but they really find this kind of
satisfaction in this constant pushing
process
that's right or they find a motivation
in failing they wouldn't necessarily say
well yeah I love to fail I love to screw
that up but when they fail that's when
they get their their motivation and and
they'll practice for another hour or
another three hours and they'll just
come back the next day and they'll say
no I want to get that better and then
they get they do get to that next level
but they're not satisfied with that
you're never really satisfied so
philosophically it's this challenge if
you do want to become great at something
to to have that resilience to want to
become great to push yourself to failure
but to also find some sort of
satisfaction in the process because you
don't want to be perpetually unhappy in
your life you don't want to spend twenty
years getting to the point and never be
happy because if you're not happy in
that process I guarantee you you're not
going to be happy when you get there
either
I think we do have good tests of
intelligence the key is to is to not
misinterpret what those tests are
telling us we are living under this I
think that's really dangerous an
oppressive myth of IQ that is that IQ
tests are identifying some kind of
quantity of intelligence that we are
born with and that we have the static
amount of intelligence that we're gonna
carry with us throughout life and that
if you have a hundred IQ you're gonna be
average you have an average intelligence
and that's just the way you were born
that's the way you're gonna be if you
have less than 100 IQ you're you're
never gonna be above average
it's just what you've got that's not
what IQ is is is is divining at all
IQ tests and every other sorts of
intelligence are informed achievement
tests are are are revealing skills that
you have capabilities this is what
intelligence experts now say Robert
Sternberg who's now at Tufts was at Yale
for many years who's arguably the the
leading thinker in intelligence now
articulates that intelligence is not a
set of innate capabilities that's static
it's a set of skills that we acquire
some of us acquire more of those skills
some of us acquire less obviously genes
do play a role I'm not gonna say that
we're it's a blank slate and we could we
all have exactly the same potential to
have exactly the same level of skills
but we don't know what our limits are in
terms of how smart we can be what in
what skills we can have until we expose
ourselves to the right resources that's
the that's what's coming through in the
science and there are all sorts of
different types of intelligence everyone
knows that by now but but the type of
intelligence we have and the amount of
intelligence and the skills that we
display at age four aren't going to be
the same at age six and age eight and
age twenty obviously we're all we're all
going to get more intelligent what IQ
the mistake that's that's been made
in IQ tests is that because some tests
are revealing a certain stability over a
population that is if you have if you
score a hundred as an average in a
certain test when you're ten the chances
are that the people who score that at
that level are gonna score roughly at
that level when they're 15 18 20 because
that stability is there we're
misinterpreting that as this idea that
you have some sort of fixed level of
Bill of abilities all it is is just kind
of showing where you are in the
population and of course most people in
any sort of race and any sort of
contests over time most people are going
to be roughly in the same order that's
what a population sorting tool does so
it doesn't really tell us anything about
what your individual abilities are and
every measure that we have and every
piece of science that we have that
defines what individual potential is
basically just tells us the same message
over and over again which is that we
with the right resources cultural family
teaching persistence all these things
there's no telling what our individual
potentials are we don't know what they
are until we apply that persistence and
and all those resources over many many
years time
the most important thing is just to keep
that Plus this ting in mind to
understand that this is a dynamic
situation whether you're two years old
or ten years old or 50 or 80 years old
the brain is plastic it's obviously
slightly less plastic as we get as we
get older but there are wonderful
opportunities and when you apply
yourself to a skill you are not only
developing muscles in your fingers or
your hands or whatever it is you're
actually most of the changing is
actually going on in your brain and
those are physical changes that can be
mapped out on an MRI it's amazing if you
look at the science that looks at cab
drivers and their knowledge or
violinists or Braille readers you see
that as people apply themselves to a
certain skill over many many years time
the correlation of their abilities can
be seen in the physical adaptation of
their brain which is an amazing idea and
if if we if we keep that our idea in our
heads and we apply that just
philosophically to this idea of what can
I do and what can't I do and kind of
push out this idea that we're born with
a certain fixed quantity of musical
talent or artistic talent or
mathematical intelligence just kind of
push that out of the way and and also at
the same time look at these great
achievers and realize that if you if you
look at how they became great it's not
that they just suddenly were great or
they were born great it there is a
process over time of how they persevered
and-and-and push beyond their ability
had the right teachers had the right
attitude and and got there it's a
process not a thing that's what I say
over and over in the book is that talent
and intelligence are not are not things
there are processes that we apply in our
lives
I've always been interested in this
question of what's the difference
between people who are mediocre at
something and the people who are great
at something and and I think a lot of us
are and it's my good fortune as a writer
to be able to follow my my curiosities
and I've done a lot of science writing
so I read a lot of science and I try to
be the guy who's gonna explain a
scientific concept to to the general
public so that's just what I do and a
lot of my work what got me on the road
to this book is that I noticed that
there was a there were a lot of
different pieces of science kind of
pointing in this certain direction but
no one had ever really put it together
there's this you know there are all
these people saying well blank slate is
dead we're not all born the same and
that's obviously true and then there's
all these people pointing out all these
all the power of genes which is also
obviously true and there's all this neat
stuff about intelligence which were
we're learning more and more about so so
I saw that all these different pieces of
science could be woven together and tell
a story that in newspapers and magazines
and so far other books wasn't being told
I think partly because they were from so
many different eras of science and
different arenas as well
Wow great question my mind goes in a lot
of different directions there I my
writer heroes are people like John
McPhee who and and Joan Didion and Tom
Wolfe and EB White who who are able to
we're able to take nonfiction to a whole
new art particularly John McPhee who has
done does a lot of science writing and
and does does that trick of taking
things that scientists understand but
aren't quite able to articulate for for
the the the general public and just
thinks about them and pushes them in all
these different metaphorical ways and
and comes up with stories so that so
that he can he can put the stuff into a
format that people would enjoy reading
and and find a way to for non-scientists
to kind of put this knowledge in their
own brains and and then of course apply
to their own lives other heroes I mean
they're heroes in the book alfred Binet
who came up who invented the concept of
IQ and developed the first IQ test
before it was basically stolen by Lewis
Terman and and not really stolen but
adapted it in this kind of manipulative
way so that by the time it got to
America it was thought to be this test
that revealed this innate intelligence
where as alfred Binet actually invented
the test - it's too expose weaknesses in
learning that were going on in young
children and say hey what can we do
about this his whole his this is before
all the science that came out this is
more than a hundred years ago his whole
concept of intelligence was this set of
skills and that if we come up with a
good test to divine what people what
kids aren't learning well we see their
their weaknesses we can we can show that
to the teachers and say alright let's
figure out how to how to build up these
other skills as opposed to this school
which which then dominated unfortunately
in intelligence for many decades which
is this idea of
of this innate endowment which we now
know to be false